[Music]
a journalism was banned by the cartoon
governments in nuba mountains because
the government they don't want you know
they don't want people to know what is
going on in government
I become a generalist to fight against
this pack
my name is Musa John a call me mosquito
because I'm always does in here and
there when I had that reason so that I'm
attack had displaced thousands and
killed six children bombing I had to go
but again it is dangerous but I want to
help my people after he was near I had
the sound of aggression
you
when I woke up I found these metal
inside my head I lost hock completely
like someone who's an impressive and I
wasn't examine them come back
unless it's not going to be like before
this it asking me completely before so
now I'm not throw us I mean worse and we
don't know what happened I don't know
actually what we happen to me and my
family
[Music]
I want to kill interviews is a video to
make the war know about this one that
the Nuba people are in need of help and
emergency medicine this is why I've got
English
[Music]
but I cannot give up I still need to go
out and report on the story of my people
you
[Music]